(haunting music)
- [Voiceover] Situated
above the Arctic Circle,
Pyramiden is home to the ghostly remnants
of a lost Soviet industrial
way of life, frozen in time.
This now abandoned mining
town was established
in the early 20th century on
the Norwegian archipelago,
Svalbard, and was named after
the pyramid-shaped mountain
that looms in the distance.
(haunting dramatic music)
A walk through this place is a step back
in time to past Soviet glory.
Remnants of Soviet culture, art,
and architecture still stand today.
(haunting music)
It is predicted that due
to the low rate of decay
in a frigid climate the
abandoned town's major buildings
will still be visible 500 years from now.
That's longer than any other
modern settlement on Earth.
(haunting dramatic music)